[موسيقى]
مرحبا بعد الضجه الكبيره الى اثارتها
النجمتين سيرين عبد النور ونادين الجيم
قبل فتره بسبب شائعات وتغريدات نتيجه
خلافات على التسريحات متضاربه تخص عمل قيل
انه كان مطروح لي يضم النجمتين مع بعض كشف
الاعلامي احمد الدرع انه محاولات قام بها
المنتج صادق الصباح عشان يعمل صلح ما بين
النجمتين لكنها لم تنتهي بشكل ناجح حيث
طلبت سيرين ترك الامر للوقت بين موافقه
النجمتين على اخر ظهور من الامر والتوقف
عن اعطاء التصريحات حوله او التلميح له
وتجاهله التمام
المحبه رد سيرين اجا مباشره
قولي يعني رد سيرين ابدا ما كان مستغرب
وكان متوقع لانه الطريقه اللي ردت فيها
نادين نجيم على تصريح سيرين بعد منتدى
الاعلام العربي لما قلت لحاله الانسان لما
يحكي زين كلامه مشان قيمته اولا وفي مثل
بيقول خالف تعرف في ناس بتهاجم لتعرف
الشيء اللي يعتبرته سيرين انتقاس منا ومن
قيمتها ومن شهرته
[موسيقى]
بسين فضل ونعمه من مقدمه قائمه الافلام
الاكثر اقبالا في السعوديه والحلول مكانه
حيث جاء الترتيب فيلم تحت التهديد السلاح
لهذا الاسبوع في المركز الثالث بينما
تراجع فضل ونعمه للمركز السادس في حين حل
وان بيس فيلم ريد في المركز الاول وبلاك
ادم في المركز الثاني متراجعا مركزا واحد
فقط
تخوت الفنانه سوسن بدر تجربه الاعمال
التوفيقيه لاول مره في مشوار على الفني
تقدم سردا لتاريخ مصر الفرعوني عبر مسلسل
ام الدنيا العمل الذي يعرض على حلقات
ويدور حول ام مصريه لابن كويس
عمل تاريخي وثائقي تاريخي بمعنى انه بقصه
تاريخ لما قصه تاريخ يبقى لازم يكون صادق
يعني من وجهه نظر التاريخ
حلقات ام الدنيا بالنسبه لي مهمه جدا جدا
لانها اول مره يتعمل
سلسله افلام وثائقيه مصريه باللغه العربيه
همم
الدقه
الانتاج يعني انا فخوره جدا احنا الموسم
الاول بيناقش بيغطي مصر القديمه فقط من من
بدايه ظهور الملامح الحضاره لحد حكم
كليوباترا ونهايته وبنهايه عصر البطلمه اا
مع ما ركزناش على حاجه اكثر من الثانيه
ولكن فكره مجمعه عن القصه كلها اا في في
محطات وفي مواضيع تستاهلي يتعمل عليها
افلام لوحدها بعد كده بس انا كان نفسي ان
اقوم الدنيا يبقى للناس اللي ما عندهاش
فكره خالص عن القصه وده معظمنا للاسف
[موسيقى]
على اليوتيوب من جديد
مختلفه في السنوات الاخيره وظروف عديده
كادت ان توقفوا قبل ان يقوم افتتاح قناه
جديده ويبدا برنامج جديد تطلب منه اكثر من
عامين ويحقق شيء من النجاح اللي كان يقترب
كثير
عرفت ايش الاشياء
هذه
مؤمن ان الناس
[موسيقى]
احتفل النجمين اميره المصري وميان السيد
بانطلاق عرض فيما هو استاذ جوزني في الوطن
العربي حيث قام بنفسهما بالترويج للفيل
وزياره السعوديه وحضور الفيلم مع الجمهور
الذي اختلفت مشى انه اراء النقاد والجمهور
[موسيقى]